growing hope in senegal how reforesting
mangroves is helping to keep rising sea
levels at
[Music]
bay hello and welcome to the daily
climate show live from the heart of the
cop 26 summit in glasgow and there's no
doubt that today's star attraction here
was former u.s president barack obama
who warned not nearly enough is being
done to address the climate crisis
the start of week two of the conference
was marked by ministers arriving for the
political stage of negotiations
but for all the continued talk here in
glasgow developing nations say they
desperately need more cash to cope with
the impacts of climate change ruining
lives and livelihoods around the world
right now
our science and technology editor tom
clark reports now on the key
developments from a day focused on
adaptation
just as energy and optimism is fading
barack obama arrived in glasgow with a
half-time call to ask are you
hoping
and individually
we are still falling short
we have not done nearly enough to
address this crisis
i have to confess it was particularly
discouraging to see the leaders of two
of the world's largest emitters
china and russia declined to even attend
the proceedings
and their national plans so far reflect
what appears to be
a dangerous lack of urgency a
willingness to maintain the status quo
on the part of those governments
you can see for the excitement around
president obama he's bringing a
much-needed injection of enthusiasm into
this flagging summit but what it really
needs is an injection of cash
his speech got a standing ovation at 12
years on from the copenhagen climate
talks a 100 billion pledge for poor
countries the u.s unveiled still hasn't
materialized it's damaged trust in the
rich nation's commitment to helping poor
countries adapt to a world they didn't
make warmer
i want leaders to acknowledge that loss
and damage is here with us now
communities from countries like mine in
the global south they're already on the
front lines of the climate crisis
they're things that we can no longer
adapt to we cannot adapt to extinction
we cannot adapt to starvation we cannot
adapt to our lost cultures or our lost
traditions or our lost identities there
has been new money pledged for
adaptation at these talks three billion
from the u.s last week and nearly 275
million from our government today
but will it materialize
he can pull a crowd but mr obama only
secured a third of the green finance
money his administration promised in
paris
we're not losing hope in not losing
faith we're continuing to believe that
it can become a reality because without
that becoming a reality what do we have
where do we go
so we don't want to lose that faith and
we don't want to lose that hope but it
is being stretched towards yeah it is it
is
but as i said we're not losing faith and
we're not losing hope
faith and hope are what these talks need
right now that and a lot more ambition
otherwise an even more difficult task
gets passed on to the next cop a year
from now and a year closer to the worst
of climate change tom clark sky news
glasgow
well we heard there in tom's piece from
the climate justice activist vanessa
nakate whose home uganda is on the front
line of climate change well earlier i
spoke to her along with scotland's first
minister nicolas sturgeon about the
challenges of moving countries whose
people rely so heavily on fossil fuels
away from them
it's not enough for me to say stop
something or don't do something i've
also got to look in the eye people who
work in that industry and say how are we
going to justly transition you to the
alternatives and how are we going to
build up the alternative sources of
energy to reduce our dependence on oil
and gas i'm determined to do that it's
one of the tough issues for a country
like scotland climate justice should not
mean that people are going to lose their
jobs that's why we say we need to stop
development of all new fossil fuel
projects because this will allow for an
easier transition for you know for
people for communities to a more
sustainable world and when it comes to
countries like mine countries like mine
are also facing the pressure of
transitioning you know the pressure of
developing without coal or without oil
or without gut but how is this going to
be possible without climate finance
australia has said it intends to
continue selling coal decades into the
future despite pledges at the cop26
summit for more than 40 countries to
reduce their dependence on the fossil
fuel the country's resources minister
keith pitt said the government had been
clear it wouldn't be closing coal mines
or coal-fired power stations
well australia is the world's second
largest exporter of coal and the fossil
fuel is the country's largest energy
resource between 2018 and 2019 the total
value of coal exports in australia was
nearly 70 billion dollars
most of the coal destined for foreign
markets is produced in the hunter valley
in new south wales the state accounts
for around 40 percent of all coal
production in australia
sky correspondent siobhan robbins
reports now from musselbrook in the
upper hunter valley
this is coal country
in the hunter valley a 13 000 strong
workforce dig and mine this land
australians building fortunes and
futures from the black gold they pull
from the earth
coal is so important to this area to
this community we believe that we've got
another 30 years left of this industry
to continue
uh selling coal all around the world so
the last piece of coal that's burnt in
the world should be hunna valley black
coal if we turned off coal now what
would happen here uh we would see social
devastation
and in terms of jobs lost
businesses going bankrupt and people
moving away from this area
[Music]
this community isn't just built on coal
it's intertwined in the very fabric of
society
people have given their lives to the
mines
the mines have given livelihoods to tens
of thousands of people
the cop 26 call to phase out coal power
has gone unanswered in australia a move
supported by many here what these guys
are attempting to do is put a dead man
switch in
on a certain date and say that's it now
what happens if you don't meet that are
we are we going to do rolling blackouts
so are you willing to roll the dice and
risk
potentially the planet dying no i'm not
saying that we should do nothing there
are things that we can do to reduce the
carbon output but i don't think that
putting a switch in which is going to
act like a nuclear bomb on our economies
is a good idea
this is the side of the house that faces
all of the bides but this has gotten
worse
but even in coal country fears over
pollution and climate change have
started causing divisions
so what is that that you're wiping off
coldest it makes me angry it makes me
worried i mean that's in my lungs too
margo's family once made its money from
mining
but for australia to have a future she
thinks coal has to be left in the past
the government has boosted solar and
wind power pledged net zero emissions by
2050
but it's also signed off new mines
we're about to dig up more to it
and and dig up more tons of coal for
many more years we just can't be doing
it anymore for the climate i think
the bill has sounded and it is time for
the
coal industries to start transiting out
of it
this isn't just a domestic battle
australia is the world's second biggest
exporter of coal
a global dealer of the planet's
filthiest fossil fuel
these communities have fought and died
for coal if australia bows to pressure
what happens to the people living here
if it doesn't what happens to the rest
of the world
is this a curtain call for coal
no i don't believe it is i mean have a
look in the backdrop of
uh cop you've got record high cold
demand all around the world so if there
was a last stand to be made on coal it
should be here in this country
the balance of energy economics and the
environment struck here will impact all
of our lives
australia is now facing its most
important power struggle siobhan robbins
sky news new south wales
well let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news from cop26 and
also from around the world and at least
503 fossil fuel lobbyists affiliated
with some of the world's biggest oil and
gas companies have been given access to
cop 26 according to analysis of
attendees by global witness researchers
say if the fossil fuel lobby were a
country delegation at the climate summit
it would be the biggest with two dozen
more attendees than the largest nation
authorities in the south of india have
evacuated low-lying areas after heavy
rainfall triggered flooding overnight
the indian meteorological department
issued moderate to high flash flood
warnings for several districts where
significant rainfall is expected for
another four days
and nasa has released the first images
of earth taken by a new mission designed
to capture high-resolution snapshots of
the planet to help track climate change
these pictures including the florida
panhandle and kathmandu in nepal
were taken by the landsat 9 mission on
the 31st of october for the joint
project between nasa and the u.s
geological survey
now as we've been hearing today's focus
here at the cop26 summit is adaptation
and there are warnings that one area of
the uk could become uninhabitable if
action isn't taken to tackle climate
change the isles of scilly off the coast
of cornwall has published a major action
plan because of the severe risk of
flooding to homes transport water
supplies and wildlife as our west
england correspondent dan whitehead
reports
28 miles off the tip of cornwall a
climate emergency is unfolding
less than a thousand years ago the isles
of scilly was a single land mass
now its 140 islands and 2 000 residents
are battling the impact of rising sea
levels and intense storms this is the
main defense of our water supply which
is just the other side of this bank
protecting the island's water from sea
contamination is just one of the plans
to ensure that future generations can
still live here what's the worst case
scenario for the people of the arts of
silly well evacuation basically because
we wouldn't be able to live here i'm not
talking about the next 10 years 20 or
even 100 years but it could eventually
lead to evacuation the council says it
must robustly defend the islands and is
spending millions on protecting its
coastline homes and businesses
the majority of the population lives
here in hue town but it's also one of
the most vulnerable parts of the isles
at its narrowest it's around 130 metres
wide sandwiched between two beaches
climate change is literally squeezing
and eroding this community
20 minutes by boat and we arrive at
saint agnes population 80.
farmers aiden and grace rear cattle but
also grow crops for oils and gin
so normally we'd be harvesting these
plants and they'd be they'd be up like
this intense dry spells are making
business difficult
summers like this summer have made us
have to rethink completely we're gonna
we're having to look at investing in
permanent irrigation systems now to see
us through it's just happening too often
for us to risk year on year the crops
failing
but climate change isn't just impacting
those on land
the wildlife trust says in 2017 nearly
all seal pups died after being swept out
to sea too soon by a series of ferocious
storms
uh this is the main entrance to the
school
fifteen-year-old will schwartz is a
climate champion at the island's only
school
he's passionate and fearful about the
future of the sillies it definitely
worries me the future generations won't
be able to have the same experiences
over here than than i did my generation
did
which is a little bit sad and it's a bit
worrying because
it we might already be too late
this island community is taking action
now
knowing climate change is posing an
urgent threat
to its very way of life
well dan joins me now live so dan what's
the way forward then
well the isles of silly has today been
holding a major uh online summit a cop
26 summit and they've also published uh
their climate change action plan it's
gone out to public consultation to the
2000 or so residents who will have a
chance to put their input in over the
next couple of months on how they should
tackle climate change we've been hearing
about adaptation all day at cop26
nowhere in the uk needs to adapt more
than the isles of silly according to
authorities here and while they are
working on mitigation so they have big
plans for extra solar more electrical
vehicles and so forth it really is the
adaptation that is going to be key they
are spending millions of pounds and have
been carrying out survey work
this week on raising those sea barriers
raising those defenses to protect the
water supply uh to protect the roads to
protect the businesses you might just be
able to make out behind me here we're
obviously by the harbour in houston and
that water is lapping against those
people's homes i was chatting to one
gentleman here who says that the water
spray comes up on his window even when
there's a mild wind so it really is an
issue which the islanders are facing it
is not an issue which is going to be
critical for them in the next 10 20 or
even 100 years but the council is keen
to stress and they put in writing today
that they have to take urgent and robust
action now and if they can't then these
people's children and their
grandchildren simply will not be able to
live here anymore
dan thank you
now one nature based solution to help
tackle climate change is mangroves the
trees grow in sea water they help
capture carbon dioxide
protect coastal areas from erosion and
storm surges and provide important
habitats for a wide variety of species
and for one community in senegal
reforestering reforesting mangroves is
helping them deal with the impacts of
the climate crisis
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
now we're getting to discussing all of
the climate issues of the day now and
i'm joined by the chair of the
adaptation subcommittee of the committee
on climate change dame julia king and
the director of the energy and climate
think tank powershift africa mohammed
adal so welcome to both of you mohammed
first of all and how important is the
issue of adaptation for those
communities who are already suffering
from climate change and do you feel this
conference has given enough attention to
it we've had a whole day today haven't
we focused on it unfortunately we
haven't actually even started addressing
adaptation and loss and damage at the
scale that it's required
if you think about the 30 years of
negotiations the world hasn't been able
to catalyze the global action that is
needed particularly to reduce emissions
but also more importantly to be able to
meaningfully provide support to those
who are vulnerable and living on the
front line if you think about the
communities now suffering some of the
worst impact of climate change we're not
extending much support to them we've
left them to be on their own and we
can't have a climate regime that is only
focused on emissions reductions and also
failing to deliver enough to hold
warming to below 1.5 degrees and so if
we're going to be able to tackle climate
change effectively we start we need to
start getting getting seriously about
adaptation so that we can actually
survive some of the predicted impacts of
climate change dave julie would you
agree with that and funding is vital
isn't it we have had some announcements
today as far as the climate fund is
concerned haven't we does it go far
enough i couldn't agree more with
muhammad i think he's spot on i mean
we've seen we've been celebrating today
hundreds of millions of pounds being
committed to adaptation we're talking
about um hundreds of billions of pounds
for mitigation we really do need um not
to take money again away from mitigation
we we urgently need that but we really
do need to be upping the amount that
we're investing in adaptation and the
support we're giving
to to the global south and the
developing world well yes and on that
subject muhammad of course president
obama was here caused a bit of a stir at
cop26 and it was when he was president
in 2009 that the 100 billion pounds a
year was promised it was supposed to be
here by last year it's still not here
how how
important is that for the success of the
whole talks that money being forthcoming
firstly 100 billion spin-outs if you
actually assess that again it's the real
needs of the developing countries who
require climate support but it's what
the developed world promised in 2009
and repeated again in 2015 in paris but
the fact that they haven't actually
delivered 100 billion and they can
actually talk outside the formal process
about 130 trillion that they are
planning to mobilize just tells you how
how these countries are failing to take
seriously their past commitments and
this is actually damaging trust
this is the only multilateral system
that we have that can help us actually
tackle climate change now if you can't
honor your past promises how can we even
trust you with anything new you promise
president obama also talked about some
of those island nations that are
suffering right now being the canary in
the coal mine and why while clearly that
immediate danger needs to be addressed
first we do need to to heed that warning
don't we so what about the uk you look a
lot of adaptation
in the uk how ready are we for climate
change um we're we're doing better in
some areas like um the the funding the
environment agency now has for flooding
but we're not yet doing enough on on
heating for example on on overheating
for example we haven't yet got rounds to
changing the building regulations so
that we're building new homes that are
going to be fit for the future we're not
doing enough about water efficiency so
in areas like the one i come from in in
cambridgeshire area by 2050 um 40 of our
housing could be homes built between now
and 2050 we're in a water stressed area
we need to be able to build those homes
to really high water efficiency
standards and yet that's not yet
happening so there are you know there
are simple things we could be doing that
we aren't yet doing and we really do
need to get on with it
and mohammed we're we're starting the
second week aren't we of these talks
there's only a few more days to go so
what's your feeling i know you've been
on meetings
back backstage if you like at the
conference so what are you picking up
what's the move that you think is there
i think the developing countries if you
talk to them the mood is very sour
because of the past promises that
haven't been owned and the fact that
important negotiations including in the
global goal on adaptation if a wealthy
country like the uk isn't prepared and
can at best be able to only firefight
when climate impacts actually strike how
important is adaptation particularly for
those climate vulnerable countries who
don't have the financial and
technological technological wherewithal
that the uk has and so because of the
failure to actually launch important
negotiations including setting the goal
for the global goal on adaptation
failing to launch the negotiations that
will help us actually define a
meaningful long-term climate finance
that doesn't just talk about deliver 100
billion but allows us to shift to the
trillions that will be required to
deliver the emissions reductions that
are needed that will allow us to be able
to actually provide meaningful support
to those communities that require
adaptation support and also more
importantly given that we fail to
mitigate enough and fail to actually
provide sufficient adaptation support
we're now dealing with laws and damage
that residual
adverse impact of climate change that we
can no longer be able to adapt to and
the smaller island states the least
developed countries are not getting any
assurance at all from the developed
countries and i thought from you dave
julia i know you've arrived today but
what's the move that's met you
the moon just met me i think is that we
are making some progress on on
mitigation and the commitments towards
um reaching net zero but but net zero is
is critical but it's not enough it's not
it's not sufficient we have to have
adaptation as well and whilst i think
adaptation is getting a bit more
traction um i think as mohamed has
emphasized so well we have still got a
long way to go to get the right kind of
commitments to adaptation okay well dame
julia king and mohammad ado really
interesting to get your thoughts here
with just a few more days now to go of
of cop26 thanks very much indeed thank
you